Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new mandalorian season 2 video all about
what's going on with luke skywalker during the
events of the series got a lot of questions if
he's one of the only people in the galaxy that
can call himself a true jedi and the mandalorian
is looking for jedi why hasn't he sensed baby yoda
in the force yet so if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos i'll
be doing videos for all the episodes this season
and we'll do a new giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your luke skywalker theories on the video
careful for spoilers for everything that's
happened through the mandalorian season 2
episode 1 just because we'll be talking about
everything that's happened so far but starting
with number five where is luke skywalker and
what is he doing during the events of the
mandalorian season two because like i said they're
looking for the jedi and he's the most famous
jedi in the galaxy technically he is the only
person in the galaxy that could call themselves a
traditional jedi there are a lot of jedi and force
sensitives that survive the purge that are hidden
all over the galaxy in their new force sensitive
candidates but you can't really call yourself a
jedi unless you join the order and stay in the
order that's why ahsoka is not a jedi anymore
because she left the order the mandalorian series
takes place five years after return of the jedi
four years after the battle of jakku where
the remnants of the bulk of the empire's fleet
was either destroyed above jakku or fled into
the unknown regions to become the first order
season 2 picks up just a little while after the
events of season 1 not a lot of time has gone by
and luke was about 23 during the events of return
of the jedi so as of the mandalorian season 2
episode 1 right now he's around 28 or 29 years old
still very very young remember the scene of him
doing all the jedi training with leia during star
wars rise of skywalker the big flashback scene
that was happening about six months after return
of the jedi that's also the same year that ben
solo or kylo ren however you want to think about
him was born also when leia stopped training with
luke and when they formed the new republic
formally so that was all happening a couple
years before the mandalorian season 1 picks up
number 4 right after leia left her training to
help found the formation of the new republic and
go give birth to ben solo luke skywalker then went
off on his own to search the galaxy for more force
sensitive candidates to rebuild the jedi order or
build his new one however you want to think about
it he didn't actually create his jedi temple that
you see in the movies until years after he'd
taken in ben solo and a couple others to train
and that didn't really happen until ben solo was
approaching adolescence like leia and han didn't
hand him right over to luke after giving birth
he lived with him like a normal kid for several
years before that happened but if you think about
the timeline if the mandalorian series runs for
at least five seasons and almost a year passes in
the timeline between each of those seasons luke's
academy would be a thing by the final season or
right after the final season so number three just
looking at the map here they never reveal which
planet luke's original jedi temple was located on
just a force-like planet like sorghum the planet
that they go to during the mandalorian season 1
episode 4 that was strong in the force pretty
much all the mandalorian season 1 takes place
on the right side of the galactic map of the star
wars and the outer rim territories for instance
mandalore the home planet of the mandalorians
is located up here in the upper right quadrant
the planet mando's former clan was located on
navarro is somewhere down here in the lower right
quadrant they haven't said exactly where it's
supposed to be in this part of the outer rim just
down here somewhere not too far away from tatooine
celeste naboo even dagobah for everyone that's
thinking about what's going on with yoda's force
spirit while this is all happening don't worry i
will address what's going on with actual yoda in
a second because yoda is not baby yoda even though
we call him baby yoda he's just a baby of yoda's
species and just for reference ach to the planet
where the original jedi temple was located is over
here on the left side up near the unknown regions
not too far away from the sith planet exogol so
you have to imagine that while this is happening
on the mandalorian luke is still busy going
all over the galaxy trying to collect as many
force-sensitive candidates at least find them that
he can so that he can start his jedi temple number
two so the question then is if the mandalorian
is also looking for the jedi right after return
of the jedi and luke skywalker has started combing
the galaxy for force sensitive people why hasn't
he sensed baby yoda in the force yet emperor
palpatine darth vader obi-wan kenobi yoda all
could sense disturbances or ripples in the force
even if they were happening in different parts of
the galaxy the qualifier for that though is that
they couldn't always pinpoint things unless they
knew exactly what they were looking for which is
why darth vader didn't know about luke skywalker
on tatooine hiding one of his children on his own
home planet and why he didn't know that leia was
his daughter in a new hope right up in her face
so it is important to remember that jedi masters
and people who are very powerful in the force
also miss things and make big mistakes but when
jedi become four spirits they do become much much
more powerful so for instance even if yoda knew a
little bit or knew about the existence of baby
yoda before he died once he did die and became
a force spirit he would definitely know about him
the way they explain things like this like luke
skywalker being ignorant of baby yoda's existence
is mostly by saying that at this point in history
he hadn't become powerful enough in the force or
wasn't wise enough to be considered a jedi master
so one he just doesn't have the ability to sense
things across the galaxy like that yet two like i
said even jedi masters make a lot of mistakes and
fail to sense things and three the force itself
or some other powerful force entity like yoda as
a force spirit could be helping hide baby yoda's
forced presence from people like emperor palpatine
like even during the prequels they were pretty
clear on the fact that emperor palpatine used the
dark side of the force to cloud the jedi council's
senses like throwing a blanket over a telescope so
it's not that hard to hide force-sensitive people
from detection on the other side of that a lot
of you were asking why the mandalorians during
season one have no idea what's going on with the
jedi they call them ancient sorcerers like they've
never heard of a jedi before the songs of ian's
past tell a battle between mandalore the great
and an order of sorcerers called jedi that
fought with such powers the logic they're
using to explain stuff like this is by saying
that the area of the galaxy that they live in
like this outer rim portion out here is so remote
that the information about the jedi luke skywalker
being darth vader's son darth vader being anakin
skywalker even emperor palpatine being a sith lord
just did not reach them at this point in history
it's like traveling to really remote areas of the
world people that just don't get daily news or big
updates about what's happening in the busier parts
of the world also in real life you have this idea
that dave filoni john favreau are trying to stay
away from doing the holy trinity characters like
han luke leia the other major original trilogy
characters that's why they did ig-11 instead
of doing ig-88 so a lot of the new story that
they write for the mandalorian series in future
episodes is engineered to avoid those characters
on purpose so they'll just continue to invent
reasons why luke skywalker doesn't find baby
yoda in the next five years or so but because they
literally just created the character that's why
you haven't heard about luke skywalker meeting
a baby of yoda's species before because they're
literally writing that story as we speak but the
whole idea is that baby yoda himself is the future
of the jedi order because he's going to live
potentially for 900 years just like original
yoda did and just charting the timeline for those
of you asking yoda said that he didn't really
become a jedi master and start training other
force sensitives until he was around 80 or 90
years old so you have to imagine a baby yoda is
only about 50 years he wouldn't actually start
training jedi till after the events well after
the events of star wars rise of skywalker
in number one bringing it back around to ahsoka
tano because she is supposed to show up on the
mandalorian season 2 and be found by mando and
baby yoda technically she's not a jedi because she
left the order but she was trained as a jedi and
is probably one of the most powerful force users
who survived order 66. so for those of you asking
if luke skywalker and ahsoka knew each other or
ever wound up meeting because we've never seen
them together on screen we do see ahsoka right
after the events of return of the jedi here in her
late 30s right after luke and darth vader defeated
the emperor and even 30 years later during the
end of rise of skywalker with the voices of the
jedi scene when rey is fighting palpatine and you
hear ahsoka's voice amongst the other voices dave
filoni actually answered the question that people
were asking no she's not dead posting this picture
making a reference to gandalf the gray you know
reports of my death have been greatly exaggerated
meaning that she's still alive at this point in
history even though you're hearing her voice with
other dead jedi but according to star wars canon
they never actually did meet in person but luke
skywalker did know about her existence he knew who
she was and that she was still alive when he was
operating his jedi temple before it was destroyed
by kylo ren this is what luke wrote about her in
his journals ahsoka tano was the former padawan
of my father anakin skywalker before he turned
to the dark side she never went on to become a
jedi master she was framed for an attack on the
jedi temple and chose to leave the order to walk
her own path after the rise of the empire ahsoka
found her calling providing vital information and
assistance to the rebel forces under the code name
fulcrum that's luke talking about the events of
the star wars rebels series and then after that
she left with sabine wren in this scene here to
go look for ezra bridger in the unknown regions
so ahsoka was off with sabine out here in this
part of space while luke was starting his jedi
academy which is why they never had the chance
to meet before the jedi temple was destroyed
and he went into seclusion on awk 2. and as
for yoda knowing about baby yoda or possibly
helping him or visiting him as a forced spirit
i think that that's something that they will
eventually address on the mandalorian series
but probably not till the very final episode
they're very precious with their use of actual
yoda george lucas has been so protective of the
yoda character in the past that he's actually
stopped a lot of writers and people doing the
tv shows and the other movies from over explaining
what's going on with yoda so i don't expect dave
filoni and jon favreau to over explain what's
going on with baby yoda but i do think before the
series is over we'll see him at least once just
commune with yoda's force spirit but everyone post
your theories in the comments below do you think
that luke would have ever eventually met or known
about baby yoda in the future my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 2 video will post on friday just
like normal i'll be doing bonus videos all week
so just leave all your requests in the comments
below and i'll name a giveaway winner when i
post that episode 2 video everyone click here
for my full mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
and click here for my big boba fett mandalorian
season 2 explainer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!